le président il y aurait signalé vite
spécimens mesdames et messieurs les vice
présidents les honorables députés
européens suez qui travaillent et des
titres divers dans cet hémicycle
chers amis et les collègues je vous
envoie ainsi tout d'abord pour cette
invitation prendre devant cette
institution fondée la ville dans l'est
de l'union européenne je voulais un
s'initier à cette opportunité qui m'est
offerte de m'adresser à travers vous
allez il lui 2 500 millions de citoyens
des 28 pays membres que vous représentez
je souhaite exprimer une gratitude
particulier sur les résidents du
parlement européen pour ses paroles le
cordial de bienvenue que tous mes
adresses et noms de tous les membres de
cette assemblée
jamais un visiteur il a visité à lui
aujourd'hui plus d'un quart de siècle
après celle effectuée
beaucoup de choses ont changé depuis
leur en demander s'ils ont donc chez
dany ces blocs opposés et qu'il divisait
alors imaginons en deux parties liestal
n existe plus jours des petites le désir
le roi d'autant s'ouvriront des
institutions européennes puisse un jour
se déployer à la hauteur des missions
qui lui ont été données par la
géographie et par l'histoire
ce rêve est en train de se réaliser
lentement à côté de cette union
européenne plus gronde dianké demande se
trouve également un monde plus complexe
ce monde est aujourd'hui en pleine
évolution
toujours plus interconnecté et globale
et donc de moins en moins eurocentrique
cette union he paid plus et engage plus
influentes au sol aujourd'hui s'associer
à l'idée d'un continent d'une robe quand
il peut fusiller et parfois contractée
en géographie qui tend à se sentir
actrice - protagonistes et qui est
parfois perçue avec une certaine
distance une certaine méfiance et même
une certaine forme de suspicion
m'adresse aujourd'hui à partir de
l'application ovi store je désire
adresser à tous les citoyens européens
un message précédent convoi mais ce
geste final sur la confiance que ces
difficultés peuvent devenir des facteurs
de promotion de l'unité
il va ainsi surmonter toutes les peurs
colorants et que le monde entier
d'ailleurs est en train de compter
l'expérience dans le seigneur qui
transforme le mal en bien et la vie la
mort ou vif cfm à l'encouragement ainsi
que je vous dresse aujourd'hui à revenir
à la ferme conviction des performances
il est le fondateur de l'union
européenne on souhaitait sur la capacité
de travailler ici afin de dépasser la
fiction la pac et favoriser la communion
entre tous les peuples du continent
hachey d'équateur mission au centre de
cet ambitieux projet politique là d'ocha
se situe la confiance aux jeunes
l'entente est confiant sinon pas n'est
pas tant ce qui est citoyen ni comme
sujet mais cette confiance en l'eau en
tant que personnes dotées d'une dignité
transcendante réparer ma titre
souligné ce lien très étroit qui existe
entre ces deux mots daigné ta vanité et
transcendante la dignité qui en est qui
est en fait conditionné également
l'application films indiens nick nous
transcendons revient au toit l'histoire
récente se caractérise par l'indomptable
centralité de la motion était humaine
contre les violences yens équipes et les
discriminations qui même en nombre n'ont
pas manqué au cours de cette perception
tout l'important est drôle mais
précisément comme aboutissement d'un
très long chemin très long cheminement
fait un bon nombre de souffrances
comme si forget cette conscience
précieux de chaque personne à chaque
personne humaine
cette conscience culturelle dame n 1 en
sol se fait revenir sur les événements
histoire 6 12 ans européenne compte a
dit steve se tasseront peine 40 these
par les bruits nous mais les fans des
friches riche vallée nos ressources
proviennent de la grèce et dans lequel
fois seul et du christianisme qui l'a
profondément pétries achats donnant
ainsi lieu à ce concept de personnes
bruti aujourd'hui 100 des droits humains
et non ordinaire farid étant de
favoriser les hôtels le terrain on se
donnerait les rapports que l'union
européenne en ce qu'il s'agit d'un
engagement important auquel est
remarquable puisque trop de la situation
subsiste aujourd'hui encore situations
dans lesquelles les êtres humains
ils sont traités comme des objets dont
on peut programmer la déception et le
formatage et juste y aller théâtre et
qui ensuite peuvent être jetés
quand ils ne seraient plus fait pas ce
qu'il advient faible malade malade et
vieux effectivemment theekoye les
difficultés lorsque la n'est pas
possible c'est oui mais librement
d'exprimer sa pensée de professer sa
contre je sais que gicquel le dignité
gatille et sans un cadre juridique clair
qui limite et qui fait prévaloir la loi
sur la ceni d'avoir quelle dignité
peut-il y avoir un homme qui fait
l'objet de toutes sortes de distribution
canada une personne est nécessaire pour
vivre et diego qui n'a pas l'oreille du
2e ligne et à travail qui lui donne dans
son unité
la mort et la dignité avait là pétrole
vont se reconnaître qu'elle possède les
droits inaliénables des coups ils n'ont
donc être de certains bénéfices
économiques convient de faire attention
de ne pas tomber dans l'équipe qui doit
être d'un malentendu est délicieux le
concept des grosses heureux abus par la
taille en effet aujourd'hui une certaine
tentation toujours plus grand de droits
individuels et j'insiste là-dessus
realistic individuelle est vrai
championnat les personnes car c'est une
conception de la personne human
détachait de la clé contexte social et
anthropologique comme une âme en reste
que comme le une monade toujours les
insensible aux autres monade présentes
autour du thème délicat selon ce
règlement
associer la notion mais c'est fini des
dénégations de sorte que je cherche à
être humain en plus de ce droit
individuel signé un contexte social ses
droits et ses devoirs sont étroitement
liées mais laissons aux signé avec ceux
des autres ou bien commun de la société
le même par conséquent je considère
qu'il n'a plus que je met vite agi
d'abord fondé rejoint l'élite ce futur
des drogués mort turquie puisse un jour
il y ait la dimension spirituelle ou une
personne
l'aîné caumont à cette notion ray bien
qu'un tout petit format taille nous tous
familles nous permet individus les
familles les chronos intermédiaires
s'unissent pour composer ses communautés
sociales et cher en effet si le droit de
chacun parmi eux mais finissait par
craquer et bien finie parce qu'on se
moque violent comme étant sans limite et
par conséquent une source et le conflit
et de violence de la vie et de la
dignité transcendante de l'inde signifie
faire appel à sa nature de distinguer le
bien du mal
interne qui se trouvent dans nos coeurs
et que dieu a imprimé dans la création
cela signifie surtout voir le nom
quelque chose d'absolu mais comme un
être relationnel nez et les maladies qui
veut dire qu'une des maladies que je
vois se répandre surtout aujourd'hui en
europe et la solitude la solitude de
ceux qui sont justement privé de l'est
on la voit particulièrement chez les
personnes âgées souvent abandonnés à
leur sort comme chez les jeunes privés
de points de référence et d'opportunités
pour l'avenir on la constate chez les
nombreux pauvres qui peuple là c'est une
nouvelle qui si on la voit dans le
regard perdu
question des migrants qui sont venus ici
en recherche d'un avenir meilleur talent
et solitudine et cette solitude dans
laquelle il a été
aussi accentué par la crise économique
dont les effets perdurent encore avec
des conséquences dramatiques du point de
vue social constaté au cours des
dernières années
parallèlement processus d'élargissement
de l'union européenne celle hélas rider
avec des institutions il considérait
comme étant visitant occupé à établir
des règles perçu comme étant très
éloignées de la sensibilité des
différents peuples et même carrément
nuisibles sur une impression générale à
distance un peu partout on a une
impression générale de fatigue de
vieillissement d'une europe et ailleurs
et non pas féconde et vigueur et vivante
car considérant les grands idéaux qui
ont aussi inspiré les rebelles semblent
avoir perdu des outils de leur activité
dès lors besoin de la technique
bureaucratique de ces institutions h au
siège aux socialistes ils étaient tous
là où gbagbo estime il faut qu'à la
téloche à tivaoune rajouter des styles
de vie un peu égoïste caractérisé par
une paix lance désormais afrique noire
égalitaire et souvent indifférente
espresso une différence est né en
virulence aux pratiques et aux pays
pauvres surtout aux plus pauvres
s'ils constatent un contrat marie-paule
vous prévalez dans cette attaque la
prévalence des questions économiques au
détriment authentique orienter les
citoyens risquent à dia c'est le rideau
l'être humain est ce que les réglages 1
du mécanisme et l'engrenage il traite
comme on le fait d'un bien de
consommation compte de l'avis talonner
font-ils d'être utilisé de sorte que
allennois l'observant malheureusement
trop souvent que la vie n'est pas utile
au fonctionnement de ce mécanisme elle
est éliminée sans trop de scrupules
comme dans le cas des malades personnes
deux minutes schipman et des personnes
âgées abandonnées ou deux enfants avant
de marquer viennet
et rien n'équivaut c'est une guerre qui
est mondiale et la juste revient sur la
technique devient un apéro niches par
réalise à ceux qui on a confié à
produire et même si confuse entre la fin
des moyens c'est le résultat une vie
rude à l'oscar de la culture du décès ni
cement et ça paiera et mentalité de
consommation hexagone au conflit
d'héritage et conan si l'on veut
affirmer la dignité de la personne qui
attend la collector précieux qui nous
est offerte et qu'ils nous paient pour
cette raison être l'objet des changes ou
de conneries c'est la vocation est dit
par la mental dans votre vote à
missionner g vous êtes appelés au
travers d une grande mission plaide bien
qu'elle puisse partie semblait a une
visée dalle il s'agit at il dit d'une
expansion de la fragilité du coup la
tragédie de la faim la personne disait
force et des choix de la fragilité selon
le décompte des forces et de tendresse à
un modèle aux fonctionnalités climatiste
qui conduit de cheminée cela lui était à
la coudée d'agir de manière féconde au
lieu de la manne de la fonction de
digital est perçue est privatisée en
exigeant la culture du défi de la
personne n'est pas difficile à faire
c'est que veut dire garder et préserver
les morts et laissé une marginale et à
prendre en charge les personnes
présentes dans ces situations la plus
marginale et angoissante être capable de
loin des 2 dauger
bédard espère en sont donc réunies
lapointe on l'avait jovani génération de
chez les jeunes générations on retrouve
la confiance par unité pour suivre le
christ est unique et on paie une robe
est native et entreprenant des volets
mais non respect de droits est
consciente de ses devoirs
talisman délai un peu cette manne pour
répondre à cette question permettez me
dit ricco aurait une image et
permettez-moi de recourir à l'image de
la france qui ne ferait que les plus
célèbres de raphaël vos idées quand on
leur présente à chaque chaîne ladite
école adaptée à l'histoire au centre de
l'image qu'ils trouvent platon et
aristote une ponte avait le premier avec
le doigt vers l'eau vers le manque d
idées
nous pourrions dire s'ils pointent vers
le ciel de la manne
le second temps la main en avril vers
celui qui le regarde vers la terre vers
la réalité concrète du pari n'imaginait
qu'ils viennent discuter cela me paraît
une image qui décrivait le colis sont
notoires de la rencontre continuel entre
le ciel le ciel du coup dur à la
transcendance et dieu ils adhèrent à ce
qui a été toujours caractérisé la mort
car il est ancré en elle et elle
représente cet aspect si tu pratiques et
concrètes à faire face à des situations
de longs délais l'opa des peines
l'avenir de leur art est qu'elle naisse
vidalon de redécouverte du lien vital
séparables entre ces deux éléments en
europe a canonné puis aux capacités de
s'ouvrir à la dimension qui sans gloire
de la vitamine t il serait une erreur
risque de perdre son habilité ou
manistes ainsi que cet esprit humain que
pourtant elle défendu c'est justement à
l'adjoint de transcendant que je veux
affirmer que si très vite et de la
personne humaine
autrement la merci des mad les kings au
fond dames et en ce sens nous estime
fondamental qu'elle christiane est sinon
ça jamais le patrimoine que le
christianisme est décédé dans le passé
culturel d'une antenne de la
contribution qu'ils pouvaient apporter
aujourd'hui d'alain pour le présent et
pour l'avenir à 507 contribution à la
paix la laïcité de l'état n'est pas
indépendant j'ai acquis sur la laïcité
des états unis sont l'indépendance des
institutions de l'union
mais au contraire un enrichissement
piano forest taffin depuis les idéaux
qui voit sa balle de plus d'origine via
trouvait dans une guérite a su fidélité
et la solidarité respirant la chute
risque est donc un humanisme centrée sur
le respect de la dignité s'il rapporte
ou l'innova allez je désire donc
renouveler les scones habilités de siège
de la cage d'escalier à travers la
commission des conférences épiscopales
vous entretenir un dialogue utile ouvert
et transparent avec les institutions de
l'énergie et son camp militaire qui
serait alors le mettre à profit ses
propres usines religieux l'appliquer il
sachant recueillir la richesse
les voiles anciennes et est accroupie
facilement immunisé contre les
nombreuses extrémisme qui déferle dans
le monde de journée accueil assez fiable
et aussi pour lutter contre le grand
vide d'idées
l'homme auquel nous assistons en
occident la suède parce que c'est
l'oubli de dieu et non pas sa
glorification qui engendre le bien lancé
m
non parce yanqui noriko d'arrêt ne
pouvons pas numéro c'est injustifié ne
pas commenter les nombreuses injustices
il ya cette question qui fera une
religion chaque jour c'est pas tellement
en particulier les minorités militaires
qui font l'objet de violences barbares
d'aller propre casas et dans leurs
maisons de leurs intérêts communs ce qui
est vendu comme chrysler lecture est
décapité ses fils aient et de chat russe
est fier sauter si les rues l'église est
compliqué détail dans le silence honteux
et complice et beaucoup
ces motos de l'union européenne la
devise de l'union européenne unica est
née l'unité dans la diversité
ma l'unita mais le disqualifie cas
uniforme de la police ne signifie pas
uniformité politique économique
culturelle ou spirituelle à unias
authentic à l'unité en réalité vivait
d'alaric et discuter au centre il
accomplit de la richesse de sa
biodiversité qu'il agricole commune m
d'autant que si que ces quarts de ces
mots seront peut-être davantage soi-même
sans éprouver aux émirats familier dans
ce sens j'estime que l'europe et amis de
saint jean est listé tous les cas c'est
souvent sentir les institutions de
l'union européenne
s'il est dans la mesure où conjuguer les
deux unités à laquelle la diversité
prochaine pièce mais la soif tout en
mettant en valeur la différentes
traditions particulières et en prenant
conscience de l'histoire de ses racines
étaient de taille en se libérant de
nombreux mails et la gestion normale
signifie qu'à placer la personne humaine
si cela signifie un livre librement
qu'elle exprime des drames en six avions
cl visage et sa créativité au service
des individus que derrick à l'épée coûts
liés à l'italie chasse une autre partie
puisqu'on a été marquée par quelques
idées de chacun contre c'est une
richesse potentielle du tout dans la
mesure où ils sont tous là qu'ils
étaient tous la peau qui veut toujours
se souvenir de l'architecturé sur le
principe de ce débat sur des rails août
et 6 ports sata mines et animale
des récits capi dj il faut que l'aide
mutuelle
dynamiques constitue l'élément le plus
fort et que l'on puisse avancer dans la
confiance que j'ai à bruno senna mis
entre le sujet et les particularités à
l'exigence de venir l'alimentation de
maintenir vivante la démocratie du
peuple de routine ce costaud qui la
conditionne homologue à ramener tous les
potins elle était même si démocratie
faiblissante constructive
les organisations et des partis
politiques ont aussi ci-contre risque
vivent dans le plein de lévis mme
delisle paroles sont de l'image un
sophisme tir de finir la réalité de la
démocratie avec un nouveau et n'élimine
rapidement dit des militants
ils police ou telle est la réalité
totalitarisme de la pire des manières
nouvelles annonces les plus récentes et
les villes et les tarifs journaliers vj
les fondamentalismes et un historique
les et x en beauté les inventer de
légalisme 100 soldats d'éléments placier
une intervenante la réalité démocratie
est un défi et mondialement évidemment
la força réal force a professé d'éviter
que l'offensé
les forces soviétiques bon ça qu'ils
avaient l'impression délit par les
délais souhaités par tuer avant la
pression d'intérêts multinationaux
universel et les fragilise et les
transforment en uniforme et financier
oui c'est donc une fête et on a suivi
d'un thé aussi l'école avec ces camps
défi que nous lance l'histoire
aujourd'hui dans l'espérance à l'europe
à prendre aussi l'esprit alors annoncé
la chaîne kalinda pas dire seulement
reconnaître le rôle central de la
personne humaine favoriser les sorties
mais aussi la capture ni investi les
rues ds on favoriser un développement il
s'agit donc je vais lui dire dans les
domaines où ses talents sur farm et
porte du fruit des fruits moines des
essais couramment l'hôtel le premier
domaine le plus dans dix ans dans
l'éducation des mains de la famille
cellule fondamentale élément précieux
tous disent aussi celle qui l'aï dit
selon la famille unie l'affectif et
elles mêmes qui en disent long
pourtant conseillé les mendy fondamental
les porte avec elle les éléments
fondamentaux pour donner à la différence
à l'avenir sensibilité construit sous la
chaabi ont fini par construire sur du
sable avec des conséquences sociales
graves et souligné l'importance de la
famille il ya le fait de souligner la
constance de la famille aime non
seulement les gars il ya de l'espoir en
obligations mais aussi aux nombreuses
personnes âgées qui sont souvent
contraints de vivre dans des conditions
de solitude et d'abandon il a bénéficié
de la chaleur d'un foyer familial en
mesure de les accompagner de souligner
soutiennent éducative aux côtés de la
famille on trouve l'institution
éducative les écoles et universités
n'ont pas limité à l'éducation à fournir
est uni siemens jeudi midi à fournir à
l'ensemble des lycées techniques et se
diriger le procès la croissance de la
personne humaine
donc je vais te tais ligier qui aide les
jeunes lui à formation adéquate et
complète a demandé à voir les formations
adéquates et complet pour pouvoir se
tourner vers l'avenir avec espoir plus
de 15 et à l'ugta qu'elle a pris plutôt
qu'avec cette suite les potentiels
étaient craint-il de lois dans
différents domaines de la recherche
scientifique
non certains nous entendre et c'est
explorer sont nombreuses
il suffit de penser aux eti d'énergies
alternatives dans le double en cette
virée beaucoup à la protection de
l'environnement
en première ligne les valeurs de
l'écologie a en effet besoin de soins
continus les attentions
chacun responsabilité personnelle dans
cette protection de la création
cette création qui traînent don précieux
que dieu a mis entre les mains des
hommes
cela signifie d'une part que la nature
est à notre disposition en jouir et en
fer de l'âge mais d'autre part fait
aussi que nous ne sommes pas les
propriétaires en passant certes gardien
mais un pas propriétaire de sa terre par
conséquent nous devons l'aimer et la
respecter alors que au contraire nous
sommes in a souvent l assaut validé par
l'orgueil la volonté de dominer la
volonté ni posséder de manipuler
d'exploiter la construire mais nous ne
la respectez à protégeons pas la garde
et respectons pas nous considérons qu'il
s'agit là d'un ton d'eau vive comme faut
prendre soin se respecte l'environnement
signifie non seulement éviter de
défigurer la tête mais aussi de
l'utiliser pour le bien commun et je
songe particulier au secteur agricole
câblée a donné
aide et nourriture à l'eau mal et on
peut pas tolérer que des millions de
personnes à travers le monde demain
aujourd'hui de faim alors que des tonnes
et des tonnes de denrées alimentaires
sont jetés chaque jour notre nature sera
fait ce que l'homme lui même en est une
partie faux j'écoutais l'écologie à la
côte aussi développé une écologie
humaine faite de respect de la personne
que j'ai souhaité rappeler aujourd'hui
en m'adressant vous c'est qu'on a mis le
deuxième but domaine dans lequel elle
est l'étalon de la personne humaine se
déployer c'est le travail de favoriser
des politiques de l'emploi
mais il est surtout nécessaire de
redonner la dignité autres des couettes
ce qui d'une part de trouver mauvais
mendient de nouvelles façons nous allons
la conjuguer la flexibilité du travail
il est nécessité de stabilité à voir des
perspectives d'emploi qu'ils soient sur
le développement du travail
notre part de travail favorisant ce
contexte social des noms qui ne vise pas
la main à l'exploitation des personnes
dans d'autres villes à profit la
possibilité de construire il ya une
famille et de cannes éduquer des enfants
à saguenay n'est nécessaire dans
l'ensemble la question n'a ainsi pas
très bon on peut pas tolérer aujourd'hui
que la méditerranée des viennent
on cimetière
dans ces matches qui arrivent
quotidiennement sur les côtes
européennes
il ya des hommes et les femmes qui ont
besoin d'accueil et dead lassaigne
récupérera l'inter santon soutien
puisqu'il ya un rituel précis proposant
de l'union européenne risque
d'encourager des solutions particulières
ce sont les chiens qui ne tiendrait pas
compte de tous les ingrédients en
favorisant par exemple le travail des
esclaves
l'europe sera en mesure de faire face à
ses problèmes de saturation aux allées
avec l'arrêté le respect de sa propre
identité culturelle et de mettre en
oeuvre la législation c'est quoi qu'ils
puissent en même temps tu ta protéger
les droits des citoyens européens et
garantir l'accueil des migrants sa place
à l'est si l'europe c'est mettre en
oeuvre est désarçonné politique juste
quoi y'a eu et qu'on croit pas et y
aident les pays d'origine de ces
personnes tournure c'est la mort sociale
et politique et qui permettra également
de trouver des solutions à ces conflits
internes étaient sans délai des causes
principales de ces phénomènes même
plutôt que de mettre en place sur le
terrain lensois qu'il faut agir sur les
causes et non pas simplement sur les
effets si un pc
monsieur le président dans l'excellence
et dames et messieurs les députés la
conscience de sa propre identité manière
également avec l'epic a demandé à faire
partie un jour de l'union européenne je
songe en particulier à ce pays de la
zone des balkans sur lesquels l'entrée
dans l'union européenne doit répondre
cet idéal de paix dans une région qui a
fortement souffert elle passe à des
conflits par le passé il finit la france
a de la présence d'oscar prix d'antibes
line dispense est indispensable et dans
les rapports que nous entretenons avec
eux les pays voisins notamment avec ce
bord de la méditerranée dont beaucoup
souffrent en raison de confidente
on a raison de la pression des
fondamentalistes nature comme ceux du
terrorisme international
c'est à vous ils sifflent à tort
mesdames et messieurs les législateurs
que revient cette tâche de protéger et
de faire prospérer cette identité roy
bennett il est meilleur à ce que les
citoyens
on retrouve cette confiance dans les
institutions de l'union européenne
guettent et retrouvent confiance dans ce
projet de paix et d'amitié qu'il en est
le fondement sachant que le pouvoir de
l'os grandit plus s'élargit également le
champ de ses responsabilités
personnelle et communautaire via sorte
de patch ou alors je vous exhorte
pourquoi c'est comment tout faire tout
cas on retrouve redécouvre sa bonne un
auteur un enseignement d'insectes
deuxième siècle écrit que les chrétiens
elles représenteront league
ce qu'elle a dans le corps il confie t
elle animait le rôle de l'homme c'est de
soutenir le corps des éléments
historiques et on instaure une historie
bible est né le rhum c'est le
christianisme d'astoria une histoire non
exemptes de conflits et d'erreurs mais
toujours aller mais par le désir de
construire pour le bien dans le bottin
nouvelle et plus encore dans la seor
bonhomme charité en modification commune
qui parsèment le continent cette
histoire en trombe au parti reste à
écrire
elle est notre présence aux fonds
qu'elle est aussi notre aide et notre
identité et l'europe et l'europe
fortement besoin de recourir son visage
pour qu'on ait l'air peut pas grandir
selon l'esprit de ce père fan tu le
faire don à près de 1 5 cm steiss et
puisque l'europe elle-même fait n'est
pas à l'abri de conflit allez messieurs
les députés européens leur évolué de
construire ensemble c'est tout non mr
qui ne tourne pas exclusivement tout à
l'économie à la paix aux footballeurs du
caractère sacré
et qui tourne autour des bâtiments
l'europe ce que vaut le pack à brac
orageux ne soit pas si toi rasé avec
courage sur place et qui te regardent
avait confiance en délire sa 10è france
vainement et avec espoir et sandales le
moment est venu d'abandonner l'idée
d'une effréné repliée sur elle-même et
suscité notamment de voir cette europe
qui soit patrice et 60 agoniste qu'ils
soient bons sauts de scientologues d'art
de musique qui fait valeurs humaines
mais aussi une fois qu'ils se tournent
vers le ciel et poursuit des idéaux
cette europe qui regardent veine qui
défraie la loi et qui protège l'homme 7
euros la mine un souci chaîne sur le
terrain
ces valeurs que confiance et qui reste
en un point de référence précieux pour
l'ensemble des unités
voilà vous venez d'entendre
les propos le discours du pape françois
en direct depuis le parlement de
strasbourg strasbourg le parlement
européen mais pas françois qui fait vous
le savez une visite éclair dans la
capitale alsacienne il se rendra tout à
l'heure au conseil de l'europe pour un
autre discours pour un autre propos de
ramadi de cette allocution papale devant
le parlement européen
écouter beaucoup de choses on
s'attendait